ich hatte auf allen sachen die im moment
fehlen gebunden expert ist expert ist da
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft hero zusammen
mit immer noch ip mit kräfte auf der
verzweifelten suche nach
es ist so ist es alle lieben so herzlich
willkommen auch von meiner seite aus und
ich suche jetzt wirklich die ganze zeit
ich bin gerade auf dem weg zu mehr
schiffen weil ich die elektrik essenzen
haben will
und da ist auch schon direkt das nächste
das ist aber auch nicht so ein cooles
schiff was ich gedacht habe du suchst
diese ganz großen schiffe nicht ich
suche diese schiffe wo es ja genau diese
ganz ganz großen halt wo ich so drauf
gehen kann ohne verdammt ja man muss nur
um fliegen die erkennst du wenn du
direkt ja kennt eigentlich direkt wenn
du auf der map sozusagen vorbeifließt
auch schon jetzt auch einfach nur eine
kiste ist hier drin das war
ich hab mir zweimal fussball lix nix
dieses ding wo wir drin waren
das war doch so eine basale gremlin
festung oder nicht und ich glaube ich
habe sie gefunden
gott sei dank alter bitte bitte es
müssen jetzt sticky pisten seien keine
pisten sonst wäre ich irgendwie in den
hals
ich bin ja hier das wollen wir nicht
war das ein pirat hallo kollege wo ich
brauche schiffe da ist in sontheim so
ich habe also ein bisschen weiter zu
normale pistensau ja das sind 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 das sind irgendwie
sowas wie 1030 pisten oder so hier aber
alles normale und ich will pisten
und dieses bekommen erstens jetzt will
ich auch schon bestens haben ich wünsche
bekommt einfach keine schreie ich ganz
so hab ich gesagt ja ich kacke von dover
depri folge kommt einfach nichts was wir
wollen
wir haben uns folgende fragen von euch
zu beantworten denn luca hat sich einen
letzten folge bei mir beschwert wenn ich
bin ja ich habe gesagt wir müssen bis
zum meer auf kommentare eingehen
aber ich finde ich zitiere da wäre ich
finde es absolut asozial von dir kevin
dazu wirklich immer vom thema
abschweifen und wird deswegen nicht so
viele fragen beantworten können ich
hasse dich das war das zitat deswegen
sag ich jetzt nur letzte show beginnen
fragen weiß helga hab das gar nicht
gesagt
mara herzchen schreibt siehst du die
hero welt mittlerweile als virtuelles
zuhause für krasse frage geht zuerst
darauf an
ich schweife mal wieder
gegenfrage ist pokémon ein büttel ist zu
hause ja die sache ist halt ne ich will
eigentlich gar nicht so sehen es ist
halt wirklich einfach nur ein spiel wenn
man ein spiel und realität nicht mehr
trennen kann ist man ihm wie krank oder
süchtig oder keine ahnung aber für mich
ist hero weiterhin einfach nur ein spiel
mit freunden das ist natürlich so da
deren haus danhaus mike maas der zu
hause manchmal der bla bla die stars das
ist natürlich schon mehr oder weniger so
eine art sollte ich bin jetzt einfach
mal kohle mit
dies kann zu viel ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen ja hero hier mein zweites zuhause
hier eine zweite wohnadresse weil immer
da kann ich immer drauf das sind immer
meine freunde und so auch nein das ist
immer noch ein spiel alle meine freunde
ich mit dir und wie einfach sagen nee
einfach nein einfach nein einfach nein
hallo ja und ich langsam also das ding
ist virtuelles 1009 man kann das
natürlich schon kann ob das jetzt zu
hause ist oder halt nicht es ist schon
ein ort in dem man sich aufhält aber
nein ja es ist halt quasi wie sollen wir
so einen ort aber zu hause würde ich
jetzt nicht nenne es ist halt wirklich
immer noch ein spiel jetzt nicht so dass
du sagst du kommst feier nach hause aus
chile jetzt in der stadt blau
ja das ist so ist es nicht nötig mich
das schlafen wir entspannen
ja genau sonst was ist sonst noch so
viel vor die objektive frage blond oder
brünett
hey du hast ein hammer von mir den habe
ich nicht den habt ihr wieder gegeben
ich habe drei hammer erstellt und zwei
hammer verlieren meint zu einer von den
verlierern hamann ist jemals
zurückbekommen
also ich hab die auf jeden fall den
zurückgegebenen schwer ich auf mein
leben das ist sogar bei mir eine folge
zu sehen habe ich die vordertür
geschmissen sagst du deine hammer museum
habe ich den habe ich aber wir haben wir
haben meine haben habe ich zurück
gegeben und jetzt kann ich an meiner
farm nicht weiterbauen
weil kommentare fragen ob eventuell die
zuschauer wissen an wen du es verlieren
hast ja einmal glaube ich an die bietern
amazon schaffen oder zwei mal irgendwie
so so oder so wo also ich hab nix davon
eigentlich verrückt man hier sind so
viele ups da kriege ich die krise
mit die ganze böse monster hier ort
sowie fällt einfach runter und nächste
frage damit wir im pensum gerecht werden
würde ich sagen ach so ja ich bin sofort
wieder da er kurz einmal abbauen
die nächste frage was habt ihr euch als
kind immer gewünscht aber nie bekommen
ich habe mir als kind immer im zweiten
game boy den zweiten pc mit zweite
konsole gewünscht weil ich aber einen
zwillingsbruder
er hat noch so lange ein einzelnes
zimmer und da war das immer so dass wir
uns abwechseln mussten
das ging mir bis ich will dann
irgendwann eigenen pc gekauft habe so
dermaßen auf die eier dann um an der
macht hier oben immer schon seine kisten
kaputt der böse
du musst hoch fliegen und den mit noch
kein elektriker tänzen das ist ja die
sache gehe
deswegen bin ich ja gerade auf electric
essenzen tour aber im tor
na ja da bin ich konnte einfach so aus
lust und laune rangegangen
ich weiß nicht also ich werde dir nichts
finden glaubt dass sich komisch an ist
auch so hab ich finde einfach keine
schiffe ich bin mitten auf merck und
mehr und finde keine schiffe wurde nicht
der tipp gegeben camp in festungen
sondern mir wurde auch noch der tipp
gegeben kämpft in diesen drei zwischen
dimension gibt ja in diesen zwischen
dimensionen ist es so dass dort sind ja
manchmal so fallen aufgebaut
ja und dort wird wenn auch viele pisten
verarbeitet bin ich gespannt wenn man
sich mal mein weg hier angucken ich bin
ich auf dem ozean und bin ja die ganze
zeit nur im kreislauf hier nur herum und
bin einfach auf der suche nach schiffen
und ich finde einfach keine trägt mich
dass auch hier wieder
aber wir haben eine frage was würdest du
alles für 200 euro machen die frage an
sich ist ein bisschen komisch aber ich
will er fragen was was irgendwas sagen
für wie viel geld würde zum beispiel ok
ok abbauen und auch noch nicht wenig
passiert bin ich wie viel sind dass das
sind 69 bälle
es ist viel dafür hatte 63 quelle für 69
bälle habe ich teilweise schon zwei
stunden gefahren
das ist wichtig viel ja mal ich habe ein
riesiges schiff gefunden
jamann
ich habe richtig riesiges schiff
gefunden ich freue mich wirklich weiter
ich bin auch ganz so hat mich auch für
dich über happy ich scheiße ist nur ob
nicht ein web alter ich habe keinen
score auf escape mitgebracht weiß nicht
wie ich mich zurück worten kann ja du
hast keine spiegel dabei natürlich nicht
du hast dich viele benutze ich nicht ich
habe eigentlich überall meine portale
deswegen ok ich muss mir noch so einen
weiteren traum finden und ich muss nicht
hier schnell fortbewegen
denn als ich schon wenn nämlich so
monster ein angucken dann kriegt man so
ändern partikel um sich rum wenn man die
um sich herum kriecht dann mag das meint
rotolo ist tot
ich sterbe ja ich glaube als ob alter
kann ich dich irgendwie retten
cap kann ich irgendwie helfen tut kann
ich ja die heimat
ich bin ja ich habe auch respawn
gedrückt aber automatisch und ich habe
mich jetzt ausgelobt das ding ist ja
wird aus waziristan gedrückt und ich bin
dazwischen der dispo das heißt ich hänge
jetzt neun verbinder zwischen dimension
ich hatte gerade ein halbes herz
vorstellbar vor ich wäre auch gestorben
oha ich gucke auf meine lebensanzeige
auf einmal halbes hettich super problem
ist heute darf ich jetzt keine news
stream oder was das ist eine gute frage
ich bin jetzt gestorben eigentlich so
gar nicht glaube ich ich weiß es nicht
vergeben
nochmal eine conti nach das ding ist
einfach nur ich werde niemals wieder
respawnen können weil ich habe gar kein
sport und ich bin in der dimension
resort in der man wieder stirbt weil das
heißt jeder wenn ich mich sportlich da
hin und her aber ich kann mich jetzt
auch nicht retten oder sonne speicher im
mix mit kaffee alter alles verloren aber
zwischenzeitlich gesehen weil inventar
walek die ziege alter du tust würde ich
die leute vor allem so gerade die kings
gefunden
normalerweise sind da doch diese
schwarzen unsichtbaren blöcke auf denen
man stänkern
er frisst alles weg alles
ich bin ja inzwischen dimension
gestorben und ich glaube dort ist ein
back heißt alles was auch sehr gebunden
ist es automatisch weg weil inventar
avantgarde leer
so halte das ist richtig ärgerlich
ja was soll ich jetzt machen nur sina
konfi nachfragen ja fragt am besten man
upstream kannst oder nicht geeignet da
schon fit ich weiß eigentlich laut
regelwerk nicht davon aus noch weitere
paragrafen
ich weiß nicht ich schrie mir eigentlich
nie war scheiße alter das ist echt mega
kacke jetzt für dich keine existenzen
hier fallen einfach nicht nur hier diese
anderen kag essenzen alle mühen halten
müssen das war dumm hoch zehn
ich hätte mich so gierig sein sollen
sechs pisten
das sind 24 schuss drei schuss von
dieser waffe haben sich fast getötet
alter ich habe einfach meinen die
brüstung kopf gefunden
ich habe in dieser zeit so viel munition
gefunden das ich hätte sechs spieler
töten können direkt und ich freuen uns
da zu gierig
yamaha das nächste mal merken dass dinge
ich weiß gar nicht was ich machen soll
weil ich bin ja wie gesagt wirklich
response weil ich in einer zwischen
dimension wind stand grad im chat johann
bett ist wissing was aber nicht stimmt
weil mein homepage ganz normales hause
das heißt er erkennen du bist jetzt kann
ich nicht zuhause gespannt als 300 fans
nie auf respawn gedrückt und ich warne
genau an der stelle wo ich gestorben bin
und wer fallen runter und sterbe direkt
wieder wenn ich mich respawn alter ist
das scheiße und das wird die ganze zeit
zu sein weil meine homepage nicht
anerkennt und was machst du jetzt keine
ahnung ich muss den schreiben dass die
entweder es gibt zwei optionen nicht
dass ich mit game mode geben kann und
raus fliegen kann
zweite option ist die resetten mein
charakter das heißt dann ist
hundertprozentig alles was ich in
veritate weg dann würde ich wieder
sozusagen als nämlich neu auf dem server
würde in der friedens staaten damit dass
bonn die resetten deinen charakter
alters stimmt das könnte auch gehen also
ich bin hier gerade mal auf dem
piratenboot und hier sind so viele
piraten das ist megageil weil ich
einfach richtig felix petzel gerade rom
fliegt und alles und das macht richtig
fand hier nur ich hab noch gar keine
elektrik essens- oder noch gar kein aber
ich habe ein sexy carl diamond ich habe
tief kopf gefunden von aktiv rüstung
alter junge das ist krass einfach mal so
einen tief rüstungs kopf also du bist
jetzt wahrscheinlich hat in der konfi am
schreiben
ich schreibe gerade stadt klare wege
dazwischen dimension gestorben das ist
ein kleiner bach er sagt mir ich hab
kein bett mehr was nicht stimmen kann
und ich habe aus versehen auf respawn
gedrückten als ich realisiert habe haben
mich ausgelacht
das ding ist ich bin jetzt in der lesung
gefangen und werde ganz sterben sobald
ich noch wiesbaum brücke was doch nicht
tun
das ist echt ne scheiß situation jetzt
grade für dich freue mich hoffen dass es
mit dem spielen dann klappt
mir ist recht einfach nur gekämpft wie
hier mit den ganzen malaga ok expert
scheint gleich durch ein joint ja was
soll ich jetzt war ich habe ja gesehen
wie viel herz nicht noch hatte sobald
ich jetzt mich in der übernächsten am
übernächsten tag respawn beispielsweise
wenn ich an einer sekunde dauern folge
zu ende
ich kann jetzt nicht schreiben das ich
bin grad mit einem kampf hier junge
scheiße ich bin ich bin verlangsamt
jungen diese pirate captains nennt die
sind ja mega krass ja wenn man mega viel
leben
vor allem die pforten sicher okay alles
nicht wert die folge jetzt an dieser
stelle beenden es schaut auf jeden fall
des amokläufers wird ansonsten müsst ihr
jetzt bei luca von crafter junge
gestärkt hat nämlich auch cap kann
fühlte mich eigentlich wieder beleben
der junge hier sind mega viel ich habe
richtig angst gerade hier sind so viel
pirate captains und ich habe allen erst
die hälfte abgezogen
gm selbst bitte eben ich habe keine
elektrik stuff ihre ketten sind nur ein
paar captain ist das original die
anderen sind spiegelbilder diesen
gleichen damage machen ist muss alle
schlagen alle verschwinden dann bis auf
einer kaste reduziert du ihn damit junge
scheiße scheiße scheiße ich habe richtig
angst gerade können die sich mir
hinterher porten irgendwie wollten sich
und wer dich jung ich muss irgendwie was
essen aber die sind alle direkt hinter
mir
es bringt dir nicht so wirklich der
einbruch die paten sich in eine höhle
rein und töten dich hab ich gerade erst
mal vor den weg oder seiner besteht aber
jetzt will ich auch wieder geschlagen
scheiße mann hätte ich jetzt irgendwie
sondern auch so hast du dein folge
gemeldet wurde jetzt angesagt sein team
vor einer welt gesehen ob es geht
ansonsten müsst ihr jetzt bei luca
vorbeischauen da seht ihr den rest der
ganzen folge also bleibt gerade macht
gut bist dann du bleibst aber noch eben
vier minuten hier online reaktor okay
gut gehen wir mal tipps hier ja wie
gesagt alle von diesen
bei redkings sind spiegelbilder außer
einer ich habe auch so ein aggregat
gefunden der auch von mir spiegelbilder
erzeugt
das heißt ja wo er hatte noch 13 leben
dass solche wohlleben schaffen
okay sind tot die sind tot
ich habe jetzt einen ninja da kann
keiner schreibt in der konfi wie kann
ich mit dem ninja gaiden spiegelbilder
erzeugen
hast du ne na.de oder captain blablabla
irgendwas becker ninja decker ja dann
muss das schiff drückt rächt sich dass
wir zum porten
wo ist jetzt mein spiegelbild der nein
du hast nicht das schwert gekannt zwei
verschiedene sorten visa spiegelbild der
so dermaßen selten das glaub ich nur ich
den auf dem server habe christina decker
mit dem du wirklich supporten kannst
dich wenn de mit dem stift passt und
rechtspfleger im portfolio so richtig
gut das benutze ich die ganze zeit dass
das kanzleramt haltbarkeit verzaubern
hält das fast unendlich das echt geil
nichts ist er jetzt eine polka rein ich
ziehe mir jetzt meine folge rein und
herr fuchs hat man hier wieder ich muss
sehen ob ich wirklich meine sachen im
inventar hatte am ende
kukksi hat ja seine folge an hier noch
drin live ist ein set r oder nämlich
einfach mal mit weil er mir jedoch
living metal diamond an electric stuff
liegt lautet ja gut goldenen feder bzö
haben wir hier noch aluminium es auch
ganz okay du auf ende jahr will aus
scheiße ich glaube ich habe recht alter
ich warte ich sehe jetzt gerade dass die
schulter gefallen bin
interessante partie
genau hier ich hatte schon alles was ich
brauche
ich konnte mich jetzt wieder zurück ich
hoffe das klappt weil sonst bin ich ganz
schön am arsch so statt blau
ohne witz ich habe mich dann auf dem
bett gedreht das sehe ich hier gerade
dann habe ich aber nicht die am pc auf
respawn gedrückt sogar überlegt spione
witz das ist ein dermaßen back ich hatte
auf allen sachen die ich momentan zählen
gebunden experte star games expert ist
da bei dir ja ich selbst kurz meine
sachen alter kein bock auf seine kappe
jetzt werde ich ihnen von dem stein
braucht einfach einbauen darf sie nicht
rein porten weil die scheiße packe ich
hätte nicht gedacht dass er mich tötet
wahrte mit dem lineal decker ein
warenhaus das ist sicher ich bin schon
tot
ich bekam einfach von hinten an und
jetzt konnte ich meine sache ich glaube
aber ich habe alles geschäft er bringt
mich mal meinem grabstein zurück im ring
nicht mal meinen grabstein zurück
der bringt nicht mal meinen grabstein
zurück tim bringen wenigstens aber es
gut dass ich die sachen gesagt habe ich
alle bekommen habe meinen grabstein ok
danke mein gott ich habe da nichts hat
in der folge bei mir ist wirklich so
bild keystone und alles was ich hatte
ist weg auch also seelen gebunden war
oder mich es weg ich hab nichts mehr
nichts
das ist echt schade auch keine rüstung
mehr und so weh nichts also keine items
keine rüstung kein inventar mehr und ich
bin dazwischen welt wo ich kein bett
werbung ganz schwer wird da sind meine
level weg natürlich in strip sind direkt
nein ich hatte 50
ich warte jetzt nur noch auf das leben
schreibt dass ich wieder darauf kann man
kann ich eben kurz drauf und mich in
mein bett legen ihn scheinbar nicht denn
jetzt will ich da hinten ja auch wenn
ich damit das thema schneller
man will mich wieder kannst respawn ok
danke konnte nicht kämpfen war noch
total gehütet vom schiff jetzt bedanke
ich mich auch noch dass er mich getötet
hatte na gut ich jetzt eben zurück in
mein haus und okay ich habe meinen die
konfi geschrieben so wie es aussieht
gibt es zwei optionen kompletter reset
ist sowieso jetzt egal wie seine strafe
auf dem chart dann könnt ihr noch
komplett visa datei oder die geben mir
kurz okay du hast mich kurz darauf boten
kann aus der dimension und wegen stream
weiß ich halt nicht so schnell zurück zu
meinem haus muss jetzt gerade ein
bisschen überziehen
das ist ein schock alter ich hoffe
natürlich mich jetzt nicht noch mal
aber es wird ja wohl kaum machen wenn
ich aber nichts an und so der weiß dass
man alles wofür ich die letzten folge
fand habe mein revolver ist war
natürlich im inventar hatte seelen
gefunden drauf aber im inventar alles
ich hab nichts nichts auch keine
erschwert dass endlich das geringste
problem
ich habe eine vollständige rückbau
dieser revolver das hat true blood folgt
gedauert wie eine rüstung ist weg na ja
ich hab ja noch nie festungen die ich
von zimmer teilten getötet hatte ja ja
ich habe auch nicht das schlimme ist
einfach nur der räuber war das 3 rob
sind die damit das ist echt kacke naja
leute ich würde sagen ich muss auch
jetzt mal weg weil ich bin hier schon
seit 320 minuten ich habe das nur kurz
eben gemacht damit ich noch eben wieder
belebt werden kann war ein bisschen
kacke das jetzt noch am ende getötet
wurde jetzt morgen keine folge kommen
kann aber so ist das leben einer leben
frauen dann muss man sich nicht abfinden
ich wollte jetzt auch nicht wirklich
gegen tim noch kämpfen weil ich wusste
dass keine chance hat sie war mein
rucksack geschäft wo alle möglichen
sachen drin waren ich werde dann
irgendwann mit tim die tage aufnehme
dann werden wir noch mal kämpfen und
sonst würde ich sagen wenn es euch
gefallen hat dass die bewertung jakub
klepis folgen gestorben ist soll ich
sagen
hamas hätte